Wir befinden uns hier in Bad Kleinkirchheim in St.Oswald und üben eine Gondelbergung an der Brunnachbahn.
Vor allem die Piloten sind hier sehr gefordert. Diese müssen
bei schlechten Verhältnissen und starkem Wind sehr nah an den Liftseilen schweben.
Die nächste Herausforderung ist für den Techniker.
Dieser muss den Flugretter mithilfe der Seilwinde zur Gondel hinunter lassen.
Dabei ist das Windenseil sehr knapp an der Gondel. Ebenfalls die
Zusammenarbeit mit den Bergrettern ist eine große Herausforderung.
2018 war ich bei der Liftbergung am Kreischberg dabei und da war die große Herausforderung , die 150 Schitouristen
rechtzeitig zu bergen. Es war bereits 15 und als wir mit der Bergung begonnen haben.
Insgesamt waren 5 Hubschrauber an dieser Bergung beteiligt und
innerhalb von 3 Stunden gelang es uns die 150 Schitouristen zu bergen.
Niemand war verletzt und alle waren sehr froh ,dass sie geborgen wurden.
Heute sind die Bergungen ziemlich Kompliziert , da sehr starke Windböen herrschen. Der Wind ist ein
Kriterium für diese Art von Bergungen. Bei der Bergung ist es notwendig
das der Pilot sehr präzise Steuert und die Zusammenarbeit zwischen der Besatzung gut funktioniert.
Der Pilot ist dafür zuständig , dass eine "saubere" Schwebeposition eingehalten wird. Der Bordtechniker bedient die Seilwinde  und weißt den Piloten ein.
Dabei müssen die Anweisungen genau befolgt werden.
Dadurch das wir das Seil nicht bis zum Boden lassen sind wir die ganze Zeit im Schwebenden zustand.
Die  Gondel kann sich durch den Wind leicht bewegen aber wir haben das im ersten Durchgang schon gut hinbekommen.
Die Flugretter Einsatzgruppe Süd wird für Einsätze heran gezogen wenn es darum geht Waldbrände
zu bekämpfen, nach heftigen Schneefällen oder
sonstigen Unglücksfällen wo die zivilen
Einsatzkräfte nicht auskommen beziehungsweiße Unterstützung
durch das Bundesheer benötigen. Meine Aufgabe konkret
als Kommandant der Flugretter Einsatzgruppe Süd ist
es dafür zu sorgen dass die Flugretter für
jeder Kalenderwoche des Jahres bereit stehen, sollte
es zu solchen Unglücksfällen kommen und eben dann
zum Einsatz gebracht wird. In solchen
Unglücksfällen wäre es dann auch meine Aufgabe
als Einsatzleiter den Einsatz der Flugretter zu
koordinieren und eben auch zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Die Flugretter üben heute mit den Hubschraubern die Bergung von Personen aus einer Gondel.
Für uns sind die letzten Meter vor der Gondel sehr gefährlich deshalb achten wir sehr auf die Liftseile und
sprechen uns mit den Hubschrauberbesatzung ab.
Die Personen die wir bergen sind oft sehr emotional und aufgeregt. Es ist auch unsere
Aufgabe das wir sie versuchen zu beruhigen und unbeschadet zu bergen.
Eine der größten Schwierigkeiten bei dieser Übung waren die Windverhältnisse. Speziell
in den Bergen ist man gewohnt ,dass der Wind
sich sehr stark und schnell ändert.
Das hatten wir in diesem Bereich heute auch.
Der Wind ist aus allen Richtungen in jeder
stärke gekommen und das ist eine große Herausforderung
wenn man mit dem Hubschrauber Bergungen von
Liftstützen macht oder von Liftgondeln macht. Da
natürlich alles in Bewegung ist. Weiters kann man
zu dieser Übung sagen dass die Zusammenarbeit
mit der Bergrettung ,der Feuerwehr und
speziell mit den Liftrettern sehr
gut funktioniert hat. Das sind alles Profis in
ihrem Bereich deshalb war der Ablauf
flüssig und schnell und darum
ist es uns gelungen in dieser kurzen Zeit so viele Übungsinhalte ab zu arbeiten.